[Music]
so I do want to spend a bulk of time at
the end talking about how do we actually
fight this stuff and how do we fix it
and things like that so we've talked
about video games and we've talked about
sort of so the social media component of
this I think the other part online that
everybody knows about but we don't
really talk about is the amount of porn
that's online there there is obviously
an absurd amount of porn and I think
that probably any of us that have ever
watched porn have thought in retrospect
we probably could have been doing more
productive things where does that fit
into the equation here well I mean the
clients that we're working with of
course are used to being isolated in a
room in front of a screen so it could be
computers you can be video gaming it
could be pleasure activities such as
YouTube and also porn so there you know
stimulating themselves through movies
through you know pornhub or all these
sites that are up there and it's free so
basically it is also a term that is
called addiction sex addiction and you
know basically of course everybody is
seeing porn in in some sort of way but I
think we're over flooded by this
material which makes with the you know
with the clients that we're talking to
that there are being afraid of
connecting you know in real life with a
partner because they're so used to you
know masturbating fun of you know these
porn sites that they don't know what to
do and how to deal with so that is also
creating you know issues and problems
yeah so when someone has any of these
problems be it video games or social
media or just general phone addiction or
porn addiction or any of that what are
what are the first steps that you do
with them or that you recommend for them
to wean themselves off this stuff
well I think like well there's different
camps say if there is a video gaming
addiction when it comes to MMORPG
role-playing strategy games that could
actually
an addiction in a medical term when we
talk about you know mobile phones the
internet you know or usage it's more of
I think we can at least call it a
digital you know stress digital stress
then basically in those terms I think we
should look at moderation like focus on
the week what can we do I mean we give
some tips about leaving the mobile phone
outside the bedroom because the
vibrations the notification can stress
us and even if we put it on flight mode
the first thing when we pick up our
phone you know when we turn off the
alarm clock we check our mail we check
out social media and we'll lay in bed
for an extra half an hour and we come
late to work whatever it is so really I
I put the phone outside the bedroom and
also you know likely to go to a movie
you know to today we if you go to cinema
you see you know flashes popping up over
every role and you know it's not a
flashlight it's a mobile phone coming up
so people cannot even see a full film
for the whole length because of they
want to see if there's something that
it's happening so I think like if you go
into a dinner or going out sometimes
just try you know to leave the phone at
home and also we have a thing called the
mobile pal it's an exercise so if you're
out having dinner if you're a coffee
shop you all take off your phone we put
it in the middle of the table with the
best laid down and the first one that
picks up the phone has to pay for the
whole tab and if you all can leave the
phones when the whole dinner is ended
you only have to take your own bill yeah
so I love that one so I have a lot of
dinner parties at my house now I don't
charge people to come here and have
dinner but I usually make a point of you
know I make sure I'm not going to look
at my phone during dinner when I
guests over and I think generally if
you're the host you can sort of set the
rhythm with that and people won't do it
they kind of look to the leader oh he
hasn't looked at his phone I'm not gonna
do it but what I noticed all the time is
that if I if I have people over you know
we started 6 o'clock we're having drinks
we have dinner at 8 now it's rolled into
10 o'clock or so once one person breaks
the seal yeah everybody does it it's as
if we were all looking for permission to
do it and and in a way that shows you
the power of groupthink to that that if
we're all feeling this and I think a lot
of people are a lot of people are
feeling just this constant inundation of
this stuff that we can kind of fight it
together too but when one of us screws
up it kind of drags the rest of us down
- it is true it is true so basically
some rules could be good I mean
definitely a thinner tables or when
you're sitting together why having the
phones I mean come on
it just doesn't make any sense so that
is what I stand for that is my personal
beliefs and but of course when we look
at the clients that are struggling it's
because of the you know obsessive
behavior that they cannot stop and and
if they are running out of batteries
batteries they get you know they are
freaking out
they are totally freaking out they were
like screaming and having attacks and we
have to look at the the issues and the
core of it and to help them through
therapy to change their behaviors to
find a balance because I think we cannot
live without technology today it's
impossible so we have to adapt and have
to have a moderation so we can have you
know physical contact and also to allow
ourselves to be bored you know yeah you
know because being bored is a gift I
mean you know called meditation
mindfulness or being just bored even
Einstein said that he wouldn't come up
with half of the things he did if he
didn't allow himself to be bored so I
think like you know you can Steve Jobs
was a practitioner meditator you
we did meditation every day and he was
the guy who actually you know
revolutionized his multi-touch
technology but what many doesn't know
that he was a low tech savvy guy and he
didn't even allow his own kids to you
use his own technology at dinner tables
they had rules and also and also the
Google founder of the Amazon founder and
Wikipedia founder they're placing their
kids into Montessori and Waldorf schools
which has non technology or at least
very little so that is the very
interesting question how come you know
yeah you know it's interesting I have a
young niece who's about three years old
he's in a Montessori School and when I
when I play with her if we play with a
physical item we're just to move things
and slide things and you know sounds and
push buttons and all that that seems so
much richer to me I mean it feels kind
of cliche even to say but it feels so
much richer and and more authentic than
the times when the few times where I've
shown her my iPad and she'll be you know
clicking on you know just swiping or
whatever and it doesn't feel real it
actually there's something that there's
just the feeling to it is different I
know so that is very important I mean of
course okay so look at the American you
know Pediatrics there are ten thousands
doctors that give recommendations they
the for said there were three years no
technology now they're being more
liberal so it's from zero to 18 months
and then from 18 months it's so sorry
from 0 to 18 months no technology 18 to
3 one hour and that one hour you should
do with your parents so you can discuss
the content in itself and it's not apps
that it's about you know playing games
or you know seeing the latest well
Disney film it's about you know content
that actually stimulates the language
and the words in itself so many people
doesn't know that because it's become a
digital babysitter and I think it's
really important that
you know parents actually take the
responsibility because we have to ask
yourself is a quiet child a good child
I don't think so they need to nag and
argue and parent has to take that
because if you're going to give them
them iPad they're going to be quiet for
six hours in a row and try it and try to
take that iPad away from them you know
it's so ironic because there's a
catch-22 of Technology here that
sometimes I'll be with friends of mine
who have young kids and because they
just want a little silence they'll hand
them the iPad like it's become what I
guess may be a security blanket used to
be or something because they just want a
little bit of quiet but I'm curious my
audience knows I've done a couple of
these digital shutdowns and I think
that's how you came across me because
you saw a video where I I had well at
one point I did a tenday thing where I
literally locked my phone in a safe and
I did not know the code which and I was
I was in Mexico and it was wonderful but
I described have you heard about this
where I actually felt after you know the
first day I kept reflexively going to my
pocket and realizing my phone wasn't
there and there's a you know certain
amount of anxiousness day two day three
it gets easier by day four I was pretty
much in bliss and I worked on some some
mindfulness and meditation and things
like that actually I actually felt
something physical in my brain not just
not just something mental I felt like
there was some stuff kind of worrying
around again is that just purely my
imagination no actually there's new
things that popping up because of the
advancement of Technology and that thing
that you're feeling is called phantom
vibration syndrome so basically if
you're feeling something vibrating or
hearing SMS sounds or things like that
and you don't have your phone in your
pocket but it's still vibrating that is
something that's called the phantom
vibration syndrome so it's a yeah it's
it's it's new things that we're feeling
because the technology is so important
to us yeah and also I don't worry but
most of us have felt the phantom
vibration but I'm not kidding I mean by
day five I felt something sort of
positive is what I'm saying I almost
felt like my
with the brain yeah that my brain I
actually felt something like in my head
like it was like resetting a little bit
or something yeah well anything on that
well I mean there's a lot of studies
doing I mean because things are coming
so rapidly and we have the virtual
reality world ahead of us and so but the
brain thing probably because you know
we're getting dopamine rushes all the
time we're getting small doses of course
not the same thing if you take cocaine
for instance you're going to get a
thousand percent of release of dopamine
so that is a high for sure right and if
you take alcohol you're going to get
approximately six hundred percent you
know sexual orgasm maybe 350 and then
you know some activities based on you
know our devices will get maybe 200 to
250 so these kind of rushes and all
these information stimulants that we are
getting a lot logically that if we're
absent of that things will happen in our
bodies as well like your experience I
don't know if that's the case but yeah I
know
you should probably be studying me or
you should probably send me to a class
or something to see what's going on up
in my brain so for somebody that's
really addicted now I get what you're
saying you're making a distinction
between you know I guess video games and
porn versus just the general anxiety of
the devices but if somebody that's
really suffering from the addiction that
wanted to get help how quickly do you
find that people can actually
rehabilitate themselves like you know I
I live in LA here not far from Malibu
where I see these things also have these
celebrity addiction centers and they say
if you go away for a week and you spend
a week at the beach you know and get a
massage it sounds like you'll be better
I suspect it's not quite that easy well
it's not but I mean it depends if you
have a treatment center which you have
to sleep over I don't like these kind of
complexes because it's very short time I
think it's good to have the open
treatment center which you come maybe
twice a week so you sleep at home you go
to work everything and you come
once or twice a week and we have 12
weeks programs we have even six weeks
programs so sometimes a client could be
we had one client that was so absorbed
by a mobile phone we call it a mobile
zombie because they don't have any clue
about their surroundings because they
are only using one fourth of their site
so he was at the subway station and he
was fiddling with his mobile phone like
a zombie and he was you know tripping
down the railway tracks and it will out
two minutes about the train to about to
come and he actually pulled up and it
was freaked out because he then realized
he was so addicted to his mobile phone
so he called us and we gave him some you
know coaching therapeutical strategies
to kind of manage so it's like time
management you know like simple time
management like okay how does a day look
like when do you pick up your phone how
many times do you do it there are even
apps that can check how many times you
pick up the phone or many hours you're
online so you can you know you can map
it out so you can do it some sort of
mind map and then based on that you you
know go in and find replacements
techniques so maybe we need to train
more or go out more and leave the phone
home more and you know different things
that is suitable for that individual and
of course every case is different so
that is more for the technology thing
when it comes to video gaming then we
have to work with the whole family
system as well as the parents or it's
not because the parents or the blame as
well they have lost the control if the
kids playing 16 or 17 hours a day so
they have to find some structure some
rules some settings so we coached them
to get back their character and we do
therapeutical stuff with the kids for
them to realize you know that balance is
good not taking away the games for sure
not because it's good it's like a
culture today they're just like movies
and music but in moderation
so in that regard it is the recovery so
to speak is that different than
something like alcoholism because I
think traditionally when people are
addicted to alcoholism and when they're
alcoholics the traditional way of
thinking is that you're never going to
touch alcohol again but you don't buy
that in this regard well for me just
take me from for example I'm actually a
recovered alcoholic as well so I've been
sober for thirteen years so I have what
they call a cross addiction so I have
the substance based and I have the
behavioural base which is the videogames
and both were an escape of my feelings
based on old stuff which I don't have
anymore I you know I've been doing
therapy but based on that that was an
escape into the virtual world and based
on that it was an escape into the
alcohol world so of course like I said
you can abuse food but you cannot you
know you can be a food addict but you
cannot live without you have to find a
proper way to eat food
and it's the same thing with technology
I think we cannot you know disconnect us
from technology it's maybe to find a
crop of way to look at it and like I
said previously I mean the DSM the
psychiatric manual you know you have the
narcotics the alcoholism and even you
know poker casino that type of gambling
is now an addiction and it's actually
the first of its kind why because it's
behavioral face it's not substance that
you take from outside into your body so
just let me clarify that because yeah I
mean it's easy to take alcohol or you
know drugs and then you change your
biological bit you know things in the
body that makes you high but if your
differences in casino so so just imagine
before I going to the casino that I have
a chewing machine right I put in a
quarter I pull the handle I get out
chewing ball so it's not a surprise like
but if I put down the quarter I turn the
handle I turn it and I get to chewing
balls now that's a surprise right so
that is an unexpected surprise
that goes straight to my reward center
and then releases the dopamine rush
through my body that makes me feel good
so if you go into the casino the Las
Vegas well it's the same principle so
just imagine you're in front of the slot
machines you get four cherries then what
happens to the Machine is it quiet that
goes crazy yeah it goes crazy the sounds
you know the delights everything to
stimulate your senses and also money
falling down to a metal platter do you
think that metal platter is there for
for coincidence
you're saying it has something to do
with the sound yes so it's just a lot of
sounds and that stimulate the reward
center and it's the same thing about the
video games and it's the same thing
about when we get the nests m/s when we
get the email sound and also the
unexpected things that it's happening on
social media come on I posted a picture
30 minutes ago I got to see who liked it
I got to see how many comments I have I
got to see how many subscribers on Rubin
report I have you know I've never
checked that I have no idea what's going
on there so it's like this unexpected
behavior that drives us and that is the
dopamine drive so of course the gambling
is an official psychiatric status today
so that is becoming more closer to the
did your gaming because it's behavioral
base when it comes to technology mobile
phones we're not talking about addiction
in the medical term more you know
digital stress like find a way that you
can enjoy life in real life and also you
know enjoy technology yeah it's funny
related to that about enjoying life I
find that even if I go to a music
concert I was at a Fleetwood Mac concert
maybe a year year
half ago and I love Fleetwood Mac and
there are all these people that instead
of watching Stevie Nicks right in front
of them they're standing there recording
the whole thing as if they're ever going
to watch it and it's going to ever look
any better than it does literally right
in front of them and this sort of
disconnect between what's happening
right now just so that either you can
get like or you can somehow live the
experience again even though 99% of the
stuff we probably never even look at
that is that's crazy but it's actually
so true I mean how many times do I
should go into a librarian' but yourself
videos or pictures in it I always say
that I want to take a mental picture and
it goes something like this
you know you just clamped your eyes
that's a full-on live mental picture and
I think that's really important for us
to have like a real experience of course
if you want to take a picture take the
goddamn picture but then put it away
and then enjoy what is happening yeah do
you know that one time about a month ago
I had a meal without taking a picture of
it oh really
there's not a glad there's not
incredible it didn't taste as good did
not good not days is good do you think
that we're in a way so people like you
that are getting this information out
there and that there's a certain subset
of people that hear this that are
fighting the addictions or that are
trying to control this or using
mindfulness all of those things but that
in a way this is so big that and it's
affecting so many of us that as opposed
to people weaning off of it we're going
to ultimately have like a real movement
against it like I could see a real anti
technological movement arising where
people just want nothing to do with it
at all and I think you see a little bit
of that bubbling up right now people
that are very proud to say they don't
have a phone or you know right now you
hear people say I don't have TV anymore
now they're stuck on their phones all
the time but but do you think that we
might get that because for the for that
middle group that might be able to
manage it most people actually probably
can't yeah I totally concede that
because you know people going back to
old Nokia phone
they don't have any displays and it's
kind of like a cool thing to you know go
around with so I definitely think it's
going to be more like a hip kind of cool
kind of thing that is growing for sure
but then again then on the other side we
have the virtual reality that is now
becoming more and merged into us so I
think we're going to have two big camps
say that it's one is going to fight
against it and one is going to you know
want to preserve it and you know like
like everything it's a debate we could
discuss it but I think like I said we
have so much positive things about with
technology but also we have to minimize
the risk that we're seeing that the
sleeping problems the focus the
concentration but multitasking the car
accidents are not being present and also
be you know being just here you know we
are connecting with other people yeah
and then it's so interesting because the
way technology works you know you
mentioned something like car accidents
and again I'm here in LA where it's a
big driver City and I see I see people
literally in the left-hand turn lane
waiting for the light to turn yellow and
they're and they're on their phone but
then at the same time technology comes
along and now we have Tesla's that
ultimately will be self-driving and uber
is going to get a whole bunch of
self-driving cars and then what are we
going to do we're going to be on our
phones in our robot cars doing all this
so we're fighting technology on two
fronts in a way and yet we all love it
at the same time that's right I mean
even in China there are lanes like
lecture meets with the mobile phone
sign so if there's the sign with this
you can go walking with your mobile
phones and there are even discussions in
few countries to have the lights on the
ground instead of having it upside
because you're always looking down at
the phone anyway so why not having the
lights on the ground yeah and people
attack problems and back problems and
hand problems right isn't that a new
thing now - yeah it's the carpal
syndrome the nerve
damage you can have by having the same
repeated you know pressure but you know
you know basically it's you know it's
not a culture thing it's about to become
a medical thing so so it's like two
things we have to look at you know the
culture thing a lot of old people say oh
you know why are you not connected with
you know real life and they're
complaining add you know some parents
coming up to me say listen my son is
with your gaming addict oh really so
many hours does it play like two hours
at least a day right and it's like come
on you know okay but we're living in
2017 we have technology it's a way of
living things not changing you cannot
you know it cannot change that but then
again you know the young kids has also
challenged it need to learn how to be
bored they need to learn how to you know
life is not always you know happy and
and fast rewards you have to have that
tolerance patience to learn that as well
it's not like a video game just press
ENTER and then you pop up again you know
yeah it's so interesting that the
concept of what is old and how quickly
it becomes old so even you know ten
years ago before everyone had a phone
all the time if you were meeting a
friend at a restaurant you might have to
wait on the corner and just stand there
for a moment and not look at you know
and just look at people or look at the
street or something like that time or
that or the other the other one that I
think people really take for granted now
is that it wasn't that long ago
certainly in our lifetime
that you would so the phone would ring
and most and it was at your house so it
was a landline and you didn't know who
was on the other end
anybody could be any it could be the
president it could be a stalker you had
your or your grandma you had no idea but
that little thing where now even we know
who's calling we know who to send to
voicemail we know who to text all of
this stuff it does kind of make you a
nostalgic for a little bit of simplicity
that's right and I mean in back in the
days it could
call on the phone and you didn't even
have to answer it it was no need to you
can answer the phone so of course I mean
a lot of things are changing and we are
learning less things and we are
advancing in different areas as well so
yeah all right well before we sound too
much like two old guys making fun of the
kids in all their technology for people
that want to that want to find you and
you know either get coaching through you
or have you help them point them in the
right direction where is the best place
for them to go well we have a site it's
very strange to kind of pronounce it
because it's actually in Swedish so but
we do I did it on google translate it we
really actually yeah so in Connecticut
in Hong Kong well I don't know if you
can post it on a site or anything but
read it as we do and do sessions and
talks as well in English for sure yes
yes somebody's interested so well right
down below we'll post a link to that and
as I said I just put it in Google
Translate and it worked out perfectly
and we'll also put a link to your TED
talk which is how I found out about you
and for more on Patrick but you're gonna
have to put this in Google Translate as
well unless you speak Swedish it's
Patrick with no CPA T RI k Winsted WI NC
ET SE and Patrick it was a pleasure
talking to you and I hope we can do this
in person sometime without this
technology between us
Oh